♪♪
Chevon:
Ghostwriter's back.
♪♪
Donna:
Ghostwriter is bringing Ruben's
paintings to life.
Curtis:
Up until now we thought Ruben's
grandma was Ghostwriter.
This ghost is basically a
stranger.
Whoa, GW's painting.
At this point
anything's possible.
(Dragon noise)
Ruben:
Mystery's intense.
Donna: Sherlock Holmes.
Ruben: Dr. Watson.
We need help solving a case.
If you want to solve this case,
let the facts lead you.
Ruben:
It's like his face is hidden on
purpose.
I have an idea.
This technology is fantastic.
No kidding, Sherlock.
♪♪
Ruben:
Look!
Ruben
We have to solve this mystery.
♪♪
Our ghost will finally be at
peace.
♪♪
(Dragon sounds)
Ruben:
Get down!
Remember you're only visible to
me and my friends.
♪♪
Amy:
What are you doing?
-Uh!
-We're practicing our miming.
Okay.
♪♪
Be nice.
You can be friends.
(Creature sounds)
(Fire breathing sound)
(Whimpering)
That dragon is bad news.